i want to talk to you about the
stuff that's available on the market
like over the counter like you've got
um i've got a bunch of them here on my
desk because you guys sent me this a
couple months ago so i've got
lion's mane and cbd so talk a little bit
about the different kind of mushrooms
and the benefits on this one it talks
about cognitive
enhancement and a bunch of other things
let's just go through them one by one
just so people know what they are and
what the benefits are because a lot of
guys are like okay so how do i level up
how do i
you know become more focused more more
productive i got problems with sleep
all all of these solve some area of that
actually
yeah lion's mane is actually our uh top
seller right now so let's say uh
nootropic it's
um plenty of research out there that's
pretty easily accessible but
um for lions main specifically it uh is
very close to what the myelin sheath
around your neurons uses so
starting close to that uh usually i mean
when i personally take it like i feel
more
curious more intellectually awake but um
lion's mane has been shown to actually
reverse
neural damage in mice as you know one
aspect of it
but a big element of uh that is
supplementing brain chemistry and giving
your brain the
architecture that or not the
architecture the components it needs to
uh don't put itself together so both cbd
and lion's mane have been shown to
stimulate neurogenesis so growth of new
neurons
and that's one of the primary use cases
for it got it
uh and is there a reason why you guys
infused it with
like each different mushroom blend with
cbd um
so it's uh it's really kind of two sides
of the same equation from
a um from a supplemental standpoint so
cbd is a much more simple compound and
um
you know your body's endocannabinoid
system basically runs
everything so it runs your mood runs
your immune system
runs you know a lot of other aspects of
your life your sleep cycle
and adding the cbd to the mushroom is
just basically hitting both of those
sockets there's that and then there's
also
the polysaccharides and compounds you
get from mushrooms which are
i mean the molder weight of some of
these compounds is about half a million
so you're talking
very very complex uh chains of
um of uh components that are in that
so um where cbd is you know about the
size of a caffeine molecule
so adding those together you're getting
the calming effect of cbd as well as
the um supplemental uh mushrooms and
there are so many compounds in each
mushroom that would be difficult to go
into the weeds on each of those
but um it's it's basically just trying
to dovetail and hit both sides at once i
noticed a lot of these seem to
help with heart health and cholesterol
like the shiitake ones the next one that
i got here
um i mean i'm almost through these
bottles there's 60 caps in them so i've
been using them for at least
um a month and a half maybe even a
little bit longer because
sometimes i don't take them daily but i
just had my blood labs come back from
my doctor on my trt and you know he
always goes over the cholesterol the
red blood cell the white blood cell and
he's like yeah you're doing very good
and factor levels got a lot better
one of the things he said he goes you
actually have better cholesterol and
heart markers than a lot of the
athletes that i uh treat so
i was kind of impressed to hear that
because i don't really like i'm not an
athlete i mean i take care of myself
obviously you know i try to eat right as
much as possible and i almost wondered
if
you know some of this stuff was
assisting with uh some of the blood labs
you